- In the research for this book,
I spoke to teenagers at
Newcomers High School
in New York City, which is
a high school for immigrants
who have just arrived.
And most of the kids I talked to
were going to celebrate
their first Thanksgiving
in just a few weeks.
And their enthusiasm
for the holiday
was very, it affected
me very profoundly.
They identified
with the pilgrims.
Now, let me give you
a couple of examples.
One, a boy who
identified as a Tibetan,
although that country
hasn't existed
since China took
it over in 1950,
he said he was a pilgrim.
Why? Because his family,
like the pilgrims,
came to America to
practice their religion.
In China, he said,
he couldn't practice
the Tibetan Buddhism
of the Dalai Lama.
Then a little girl
spoke up, and she said,
"Oh, that's like my family.
We came here from Egypt
because we're Copts,"
and Copts are an early
version of Christianity,
an early sect of Christianity.
So these kids really got it.
And then a week or two
later, after Thanksgiving,
I went to a Hanukkah party
of a group from my
husband's family.
And I met a kid
who was attending
one of the most prestigious
public high schools in America,
hearing that I wrote a book
on Thanksgiving, he started,
he said, "Oh, that's the holiday
that we celebrate for
murdering all the Indians."
And you know, I thought...
- A prestigious high
school. Ugh. Okay.
- Yeah. So who got it right?
(dramatic theme music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, and joining
me on this very special week
is a senior fellow at
the Hudson Institute,
author of "Thanksgiving:
The Holiday at the Heart
of the American Experience,"
and the presenter in
the Prager U. video
"Lincoln and Thanksgiving,"
Melanie Kirkpatrick. Welcome
to "The Rubin Report."
- It's wonderful to be with you,
especially on Thanksgiving week.
- It seemed like
you were the person
to talk to on Thanksgiving.
I have a lot of questions
about Thanksgiving.
You're the, are you the
preeminent Thanksgiving expert
in America?
- Well, I don't want to sound
immodest, but perhaps so.
- Pretty good. All right.
So I have a lot of
questions about tryptophan,
but I think you
mostly want to focus
on the history of
Thanksgiving. Is that correct?
- Sounds like a good idea,
though tryptophan has
come up, you know.
It's one of the reasons
everybody loves Thanksgiving.
It helps put you to sleep.
- Puts you to sleep.
You unbuckle the pants.
You're good to go. All right.
So let's talk,
because this actually is a
very special Thanksgiving,
Thanksgiving 2021.
This is the 400th
anniversary of Thanksgiving.
I feel like a lot of
people don't know that.
So let's do a little 101.
What happened 400
years ago back in 1621?
- The first thing I'll mention
is that there are two
eyewitness accounts by pilgrims
of the first Thanksgiving,
and neither one of them uses
the word "Thanksgiving,"
which was kind of interesting.
That's been imposed on
it over the centuries.
But it dovetails with
the pilgrims' idea
of what a Thanksgiving is.
It's a day for
expressing gratitude.
It was always a
religious holiday,
but the event of
1621 was probably
more of a harvest festival.
But that doesn't mean we
can't call it a Thanksgiving,
because if you read those
two first-person accounts
by pilgrim Edward Winslow
and William Bradford, the
governor of Plymouth Colony,
they present an event
that was very much
like the one we celebrate
today, at least in spirit.
The spirit of gratitude
was at the forefront.
It was the spirit of amity
with the Native Americans.
It was a time of sharing.
It was a time of fellowship,
and it was a time of peace.
And one of the
things I object to
is the modern-day, progressive
interpretation of that day
as the beginning of
a period, you know,
the destruction of the
Native American peoples,
and that's completely wrong,
because, if anything,
the first Thanksgiving
points the way to
the multicultural
people we have become,
because the Native
Americans and the Indians
were celebrating together,
peacefully and in harmony.
- Yeah. So it's hard for a
lot of people to believe that.
And I don't want to dwell on
it, because it's not true.
You discuss it in the book.
You discuss it in
the Prager U. Video.
But can you just, just
for another minute or two,
just explore that a little bit,
that, you know, people have
this idea that they were,
they were just there to kill
each other or whatever it is,
whatever the modern
version of all this is.
But really, 400 years ago,
the Native Americans and the
pilgrims were sitting down,
and they were saying, "Hey,
we can be thankful together
on this land
peacefully together."
- Yes. Yes, they were.
And the pilgrims had a
lot to be thankful for,
for the assistance of
the Native Americans.
They probably would
not have survived
had they not received
the instruction
from the Native Americans
on how to plant,
where to find good hunting
grounds and good fishing waters.
So, and, and they knew it.
There were 52 pilgrims present
at that first Thanksgiving.
And most of them, only
about half of them were men.
And yet there were 90
Indian warriors present.
So you can see why they might
have been a little wary.
And that was probably one
reason that they decided
to have a shooting presentation.
They showed the Native Americans
how, you know, their guns
and how they could use them.
And it might've been
in part a warning.
But at the same time,
they were very grateful for the
help of the Native Americans
that made it possible
for them to survive.
- So you tell the
story of Thanksgiving,
because it didn't
exactly become a holiday
right then and there,
that there are two sort of
people that were integral
to the story of Thanksgiving.
One of the people we know well.
One, we don't know as well,
although you just wrote a book,
I believe, about
the second person.
So tell us about
those two people.
- The first one is
President Lincoln,
and the second is
Sarah Josepha Hale.
And the link between the
two of them is Thanksgiving.
Hale was the most influential
woman of the 19th Century.
She was editor of "Godey's
Lady's Book" for 50 years,
and this was one of
the most widely read
and widely circulated
magazines in the 19th Century.
And it's kind of an amazing
story of how a widow
with five small children rose
to such an exalted position,
but she did.
And she was very keen on
using, well, let me back up.
She was born in 1788,
and she believed
that while America
had been unified politically
through the revolution,
it was not unified culturally.
And she set out to help
do that in her magazines.
She published American authors
writing on American subjects,
which seems unusual
from the point of view
of the 21st Century.
But back then, it was
commonplace for publications
to steal articles from
Britain or other publications
and republish them without
credit in their own publication.
But she had a different
vision for her magazine.
She wanted to have
a focus on America
and a focus on American authors.
So she published such
authors as Edgar Allen Poe
and the young Harriet
Beecher Stowe.
Many, many others.
But the idea of Thanksgiving
was a part of her vision
of creating an American culture.
Thanksgiving was very popular
in New England, of course,
and she had grown up
loving the holiday.
There were Thanksgivings
celebrated in the other states
and territories as well,
but the governors of the
states didn't coordinate
on the holiday.
Each was...
And sometimes some states didn't
bother to celebrate at all.
So you had a
situation, for example,
in 1837, Hale was
living in Boston,
which celebrated on one day.
She was from New Hampshire,
which celebrated on another day.
And her magazine was
headquartered in Philadelphia,
and Pennsylvania wasn't
celebrating at all that year.
So her vision was to
have Americans celebrate
on the same day every year.
She thought that giving thanks,
the idea of coming
together to give thanks
as a nation would help.
It had a higher moral
principle, she believed,
and that it would bring
the country together
in a positive way.
And as the country moved
closer to civil war,
she hoped that it
would prevent that war.
Obviously, she didn't succeed,
but in 1863, President
Lincoln took up her idea,
which had been rejected by
four previous presidents,
and decided to call a
national Thanksgiving.
- So basically it
took over 200 years
of sort of a mishmosh of,
you know, who's doing it,
when are they doing it,
why are they doing it.
And then finally Lincoln said,
okay, we're all gonna do it.
And then did everyone
kind of fall in place
and immediately
say, let's do it?
- The South didn't want
to listen to Lincoln
during the Civil War, of course,
but the Union rallied very
positively to his call.
And after the war, the
Southern states slowly,
you know, one by one,
came together as well
on Thanksgiving Day.
- Yeah. One of the
things you mentioned
in the Prager U. video
is that the people
were actually eating the
same stuff, in many cases,
that we eat now.
It was turkey and pumpkin pie,
which is sort of-
- Yeah!
- It's fun that we're
still eating the same stuff
a couple hundred years after.
- And, you know, that goes
back much farther than 1863.
In the 1800s, I
found many examples
of turkey and pumpkin pie
appearing on Thanksgiving menus.
So, and those, you know,
were native to the
country and so,
to North America, at least,
so it's not surprising.
There've been many changes in
the menu over the years too.
For example, in New
England, chicken pot pie
was a standard feature of
the Thanksgiving buffet.
Venison also appeared on a
lot of Thanksgiving tables,
and the tradition of pies was,
you didn't have just one.
You had an array, a big
selection of pies at the time.
So, but the, from the beginning,
I think Thanksgiving
has been a feast.
And that certainly
is true today.
- Yeah. You know, I
don't want to focus
on the cancel culture
aspect of this.
We did a show on
Christopher Columbus
a couple months ago,
and I try not to focus
on all of that stuff.
However, this is now a holiday
that is sort of under attack.
It represents the
goodness of America
and all the good things that
we should be thankful for.
And there's an awful lot of
people that aren't thankful
for these days,
or aren't thankful
for everything we
have these days.
What can we do to
push back on that?
- Well, we can learn the
history of the holiday
for one thing.
The teaching of the holiday
has been poor over the years.
Native Americans
understandably object
to what, at least
when I was growing up,
the focus on the
generosity of the pilgrims,
rather than on the
generosity and assistance
of the Native Americans.
So we can get that right
in teaching children
about the holiday.
I also think we can
listen to immigrants when it
comes to their understanding
of the holiday.
Thanksgiving is
a rite of passage
for most immigrants to America.
It's part of joining
the American family.
This is a very positive thing.
And in the research
for this book,
I spoke to teenagers at
Newcomers High School
in New York City,
which is a high school
for immigrants who
have just arrived.
And most of the kids I talked to
were going to celebrate
their first Thanksgiving
in just a few weeks.
And their enthusiasm
for the holiday was,
it affected me very profoundly.
They identified
with the pilgrims.
Now, let me give you
a couple of examples.
One, a boy who
identified as a Tibetan,
although that country
hasn't existed
since China took
it over in 1950,
he said he was a pilgrim.
Why? Because his family,
like the pilgrims,
came to America to practice
their religion in China.
He said he couldn't practice
the Tibetan Buddhism
of the Dalai Lama.
Then a little girl spoke up,
and she said, "Oh,
that's like my family.
We came here from Egypt,
because we're Copts,"
and Copts are an early
version of Christianity,
an early sect of Christianity.
So these kids really got it.
And then a week or two
later after Thanksgiving,
I went to a Hanukkah party
of a group from my
husband's family.
And I met a kid
who was attending
one of the most prestigious
public high schools in America,
hearing that I wrote a book
on Thanksgiving, he started,
he said, "Oh, that's the
holiday that we celebrate
for murdering all the Indians."
And you know, I thought-
- A prestigious high
school. Ugh. Okay.
- Yeah. So who got it right?
So education is, is one thing.
And let me end on a
positive note here, though.
You know, yes, progressives
are out to cancel Thanksgiving,
but I don't think they
have a hope of success,
because Americans like
this holidays so much.
And even if they don't fully
grasp the history of it,
or even if they pay lip
service to the cancel culture,
they're not going to stop
celebrating Thanksgiving.
And also, I think a lot
of very positive aspects
of Thanksgiving are
going to continue.
Families are going
to come together.
Americans have a tradition
of inviting people
who have no place to
go for Thanksgiving.
And most of all, I love the
idea of Thanksgiving generosity,
which, the idea that
Thanksgiving is a holiday
when we think carefully
about those who are
less fortunate among us.
And you think of
all the non-profits,
all the non-religious, all
the religious organizations,
and also all the individuals
who make sure that
people who are in jail,
people who are in hospital,
and people who have
no family at all
have an opportunity to have
a good Thanksgiving dinner.
And this is a real
hallmark of the holiday
and of American generosity.
- Yeah, and I have to
say that, you know,
over the last couple of years,
as some of our freedoms have
felt like they're disappearing,
or at least being challenged
in very bizarre ways,
I've definitely become
more appreciative.
I've always loved Thanksgiving,
because of the
food and the smells
and the people and the
family and all that.
You mentioned at the beginning
that this was really thought
of as a religious holiday
at first, which is
sort of not the way
I think most people think of it,
because they think of it sort
of as our main secular holiday
in America.
Can you talk about
that a little bit?
- Yeah. I think a better
way to think of it, Dave,
is that it is the only holiday
probably anywhere in the world
that is open to all
religions and to none.
So it's, you know, doesn't
matter what your religion is.
Doesn't matter
where you came from.
It is every American's holiday.
So, yeah, it used to be,
even when I was growing up,
that people went to
church, you know,
the night before Thanksgiving
or Thanksgiving morning.
That doesn't happen
very much anymore.
But if there is a day
that a family says grace
before a meal, it
is Thanksgiving Day.
- Yeah. So you mentioned
before that Abraham Lincoln,
obviously first, we
have the Civil War,
so now he's got to get the
South to kind of come on board,
all of this.
Was everybody immediately
celebrating Thanksgiving after,
or did it really take some time?
- It took a while. I don't
recall off the top of my head
the dates when the
Southern states
individually began to celebrate,
but certainly by
the end of the 19th,
beginning of the 20th Century,
there was unity in the states.
And let me tell
you a funny story
about what happened
in the 1930s.
During the Depression,
FDR had the dumb idea
that if he moved the
date of Thanksgiving
to allow more time
between Thanksgiving
Day and Christmas,
it would help the economy.
His theory was that Americans
would have more days
to go Christmas shopping,
and that would be a
boost to the holiday.
Well, I think Americans would
have liked to spend more money
on Christmas presents, but
they didn't have the money.
- [Dave] Right.
- So the idea flopped, but,
and for three days though,
Americans had to either
celebrate on the new day,
which was a week earlier
than the traditional date,
or celebrate on the
traditional date.
And the country was
split about 50-50.
And the holiday began known as,
became known as the
Democratic Thanksgiving
and the Republican Thanksgiving,
which was very funny,
but there were a few states
that had the best idea of all.
They celebrated on both days.
And I know Texas and
Colorado were among them.
I've forgotten
what the third is.
But then in 1941, it was
clear that Roosevelt's idea
for a new date for
Thanksgiving was a flop,
and Congress finally acted
and passed a resolution
naming the fourth
Thursday of November
as the official
Thanksgiving date,
and finally Thanksgiving
was written into law,
and we've celebrated on
that date ever since.
- As a Thanksgiving historian,
does it madden you that
Friday after Thanksgiving
has now become Black Friday,
which is now leaking
into Thanksgiving?
I mean, the new thing is now
that the stores open actually
on Thanksgiving Day, the
one day we're supposed
to set aside to be thankful,
and we've allowed it
to become this sort
of commercial madness.
- Yeah, I don't like the leakage
into Thanksgiving Thursday,
I say.
But I don't mind Black Friday.
I think it's actually a sign
of the health of our economy,
the prosperity of
the American people.
And we should give thanks.
We should pay thanks.
Give thanks for that.
- How did football-?
- I also-
- Oh, go ahead.
- Well, football.
(she chuckles)
What about football?
- Yeah. How did football become
a part of this whole thing?
I thought football was
supposed to be on Sundays.
- Well, I am not
a fan of football,
and this was the hardest
chapter for me to write.
But I had a lot, you know,
I did a lot of research,
and I got it.
As you may recall, the
first American football game
was played by Princeton
and Rutgers in 1869.
And then in the 70s, Princeton,
which is my alma mater,
I will say,
and Yale played a Thanksgiving
Day football game.
It was their championship game.
That moved to New York
City in the late 1870s
or around 1880, and
New Yorkers took it up.
Even if they couldn't
go to the game,
they came out in force,
walking the streets.
They would go up and
down Fifth Avenue
wearing orange and
black for Princeton
or blue for Yale.
And they really adopted this
football championship game
in a big way.
And of course, New Yorkers
have always been trendsetters,
and the rest of the country
began to take up the idea
of Thanksgiving Day football.
A lot of towns would have,
town high schools would
have their championship game
on Thanksgiving morning and
then go home for dinner.
And then I guess some
people had the idea
in the early 20th Century
that this would be good
for pro football too.
And the Detroit Tigers
were the first team
to play a Thanksgiving Day game,
which they, of
course, still play.
And then the Dallas Cowboys
took it up at some point.
And now there's a third team,
which I think changes
every year that plays.
But Thanksgiving football
was controversial
in the 19th Century.
Ministers and rabbis
and others complained
that it took, it
diverted attention
from the true
meaning of the day.
But, you know, I, I
think we can have turkey
and football and gratitude
all in the same day.
We can multitask.
- Right, right.
Although I'm sure
there were some people,
of course, that probably felt
that people shouldn't be, you
know, forced to work that day
or that sort of thing too,
but you think we can
fit all the things.
What are some of the crazier
traditions you've heard?
I assume that there's all sorts
of different Thanksgiving
traditions all over the country.
- Gosh. Yeah, there
are, but you know,
the meal is the number one,
is the number one tradition,
and Sarah Josepha Hale,
who I mentioned is the godmother
of the modern-day Thanksgiving,
she was the first
one to bring recipes,
to put recipes in a
magazine or newspaper,
to create a recipe section.
And she published
lots of recipes
culled from around the country
for Thanksgiving Day feasts.
And you know, you hear, I
heard of some crazy pies
like sweet potato pie.
I had never heard of that,
but apparently it's
popular in the South.
And there's a pie
called Marlborough pie,
which is a kind of
apple lemon pie,
which was very popular
in the 19th Century.
But crazy customs.
A lot of people go,
this isn't crazy,
but a lot of people
go around the table
and ask every individual
to say something that
he is grateful for.
- [Dave] Yep, we do
that. We do that.
- Other families read,
find something to read
about Thanksgiving
for the family table.
And I actually, at the back
of my Thanksgiving book,
include readings for
Thanksgiving Day.
And they're short,
very short, readings
from over 400 years of American
history about Thanksgiving.
And then there's a custom
that my family has adopted.
I won't call it a crazy custom,
but it's a different custom.
It's called "Five
Kernels of Corn."
And it dates back to
the late 19th Century.
People would put five kernels
of dried corn on their table.
And the corn represented the
generosity of the native people
who taught the pilgrims
how to grow corn.
And it also represented the
starving time of the Plymouth,
of the pilgrims in
Plymouth Colony, when they,
legend says, were given
only five kernels of corn
to eat every day.
So, I like that.
I like that idea.
Five kernels of corn.
- How does our Thanksgiving,
some of the traditions,
the foods, all that,
compare, you know,
like we just had
Canadian Thanksgiving
was a couple of weeks ago.
I assume other countries
have some version,
maybe not called
Thanksgiving, but you know,
sort of a more secular day
of thanks type of thing.
- Well, most of the
Thanksgivings around the world
are religious in nature, or
at least originated as such.
China has a kind
of Thanksgiving.
It's more of a harvest festival.
So do the two Koreas.
Brazil has a Thanksgiving
that is modeled on the
American Thanksgiving.
The ambassador from Brazil
to America in the late 1940s
loved Thanksgiving.
And so he went home and
took it with him to Brazil,
and they now have
such a holiday.
And Canada's holiday
is interesting.
It's on our Columbus
Day weekend.
The idea of celebrating
Thanksgiving
was carried to Canada by
British loyalists, who,
American loyalists, excuse me,
who fled during the revolution
to usually Nova Scotia.
And because there was a close
tie between Boston and Halifax
at the time,
and they took the
holiday with them,
and it spread around
the country of Canada.
It doesn't have the same
meaning for Canadians, though,
that it has for Americans,
because it's not,
it doesn't have an
association with anything
in the Canadian history.
So while Canadians enjoy
the day and have a meal,
a harvest meal that's
similar to ours,
they don't feel the
connection to it that we feel.
- Interesting.
So it really was an
export from us to them.
- Yeah.
- In that sense.
- Yeah. Yep.
- Interesting. What else
do people need to know
on this Thanksgiving
before I let them dive
into their turkey and stuffing
and all that good stuff,
their sweet potato pie?
- Well, I, in response
to your comment about,
your question
about Black Friday,
I also wanted to
mention Giving Tuesday,
which you may have heard of.
It's a relatively new campaign,
which was originally
organized by the 92nd Street Y
in New York City,
which has Jewish roots.
And the idea was
to set up online
opportunities for
people to donate
to their favorite
non-profits and charities.
It's been very successful.
It's raised millions,
it raises millions and
millions of dollars every year.
- [Dave] Wow.
- And I love the idea
that Giving Tuesday
is connected, originally,
to our Thanksgiving Day.
- Do you know the actual
website we can send people to?
We'll find it if not.
- Well, I don't.
I believe the way it
works is that you go...
Well, I'm not sure.
Yeah. See if you can find a
link. That would be great.
- I'm guessing there's a
Giving Tuesday website,
but if not obviously on that
Tuesday before Thanksgiving,
you can, you can donate
to wherever you'd like.
Well, we're gonna link to the
Prager U. video down below.
We're going to link to the
book, which I've got right here,
and I've enjoyed this talk,
and I can very simply say
happy Thanksgiving to you.
- And back to you, Dave.
I wish you and your family
a very happy Thanksgiving.
- If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about academia,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our academia playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
check out our full
episode playlist.
They're all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.